皆さん人前で話すときに緊張したことはありませんか
おそらく誰もが一度はそのような経験をしたことがあるでしょう
私は特に話すことが苦手です
だから自分が本当に伝えたい気持ちはこのようにして伝えます
[音楽]
いいいい
楽しみ
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
このようにギターを片手に持ち
メロディに乗せながら伝えます
何故かといえば
歌うことが
自分が一番楽しんでいる姿を表現できるからです
今はこうですが
昔は言葉で伝えようともがいて
だけど話の上手い人にはどうしてもかなわないなと思うような
芯のない大学生でした
そんな私を変えるきっかけとなったのが学部の復興支援プログラムでした
復興支援プログラムでは被災地の方と触れ合い
大抵は話をするイベントがあるのですが
他のメンバーが上手に話を盛り上げる中
分にはそれができない
私はただ焦るばかりでした
そんなとき源氏の小学校に行くことになり
そこでもうすぐ二分の一成人式を迎える
小学生たちに
大学生である私たちの子どものころの夢の話をすることになりました
私の子供の頃の夢は歌手でそのことを知っていたスタッフさんがせっかくだし歌ってみ
たらと言ってくださったので急遽
歌うスピーチをすることになりました
小学校に来てまず給食を一緒に食べながら子どもたちとお話ししたのですが
その時は全くな疲れませんでした
そしていよいよ夢の話をするイベントになりました
子供の頃ずっと歌手になりたいと思い続けたこと
だから好きなことが胸にあるならずっと追い続けてほしいこと
そして自分の夢のために書いた決意の歌
ビーチの終わった瞬間
なんとたくさんの子供たちが駆け寄ってきてくれたのです
そして自分の好きなこと将来の夢について次々と語ってくれ
お姉さんのスピーチを聞いて自分も夢に向かって頑張りたいと思ったと言ってくれたの
です
今まで触れ合ってきた人の心
開くことの出来なかった自分には
変えられないことでした
それ以来私は避難所や授業でこの歌うスピーチをしてきました
そして今まで動かす事の出来なかった人の心
出会うたびに動かすことができました
自分の好きなことからはじめるコミュニケーションで
子どもたちから高齢の方まで取材を超えて
心を通わせることができたのです
これは歌だけに限りません
例えばダンスあ
あなたがもし愛する人にダンスと共にプロポーズしたなら
より情熱的に思いが伝わるでしょう
最近ではフラッシュモブという方法でも流行っていますよね
例えばエア写真
もしあなたが外国人に
1枚の写真を持って見えたなら a
その人との間に会話が生まれ仲良くなれるかもしれません
東京オリンピックが開催され日本がグローバル化する
2021年
だからこそ言葉にこだわらず
思い切って自分の好きなことからコミュニケーションしてみましょう
もっと身軽に
日常生活で
好きなものを持って
特別な技術やステージは必要ありません
[音楽]
ni